la deuxième moitié du siècle que nous
vivons sera certainement marqué par la
prolifération des sites est rendue
nécessaire au logement des populations
qui viennent s'agglutiner autour des
villes souvent historiques mais toujours
inadapté un tel afflux de familles mais
de tels ensembles vaste qui réunissent
de nombreux foyers sont d'ailleurs créé
deux communautés réel pose le problème
de l'occupation des jeunes angoulême
nous vous conduisons ce soir n'échappe
pas à cette loi est cependant dans la
grande ville charentaise une
intéressante initiative a vu le jour
réunir de jeunes enfants des garderies
pour chanter ensemble un excellent moyen
sans doute pour leur apprendre à mieux
se connaître et pour exprimer leur joie
de vie nous rejoignons ces jeunes
enfants dans le car qui les emmène à une
répétition sous la conduite de leur
jeune et enthousiaste animateur jean
jacques fiolet
combien yat-il d'enfants qui participent
à cette chorale il ya exactement
soixante treize enfants
quarante six filles et 27 garçons en
général ils sont tous des grands
ensembles et en particulier de bel air
de basseau de la grande garenne et un
quartier quand même plus anciens ça si
bas et on l'a fait dans ce but surtout
pour distraire les jeunes de quel âge à
quel âge va l'échelle alors pour les
filles de 7 à 16 ans pour les garçons de
7 à 13 ans pour la bonne raison que à
part on considère qu'à partir de 13 ans
un garçon commence à me voyez c'est à
dire comme un gosse comme thierry il
chantera jusqu'à peut-être jusqu'à 12
présence tranquille mais on le garde en
conservant dans la chorale mais après il
voir chanter après à partir de 16 ans
thierry aime tu chanter oui oui
et combien de fois tu participes à des
répétitions comme ça par semaine il y en
a une deux ou trois fois
des fois deux fois par semaine et tu
prends le quart comme ça à 7h30 oui ou
ramasser donc que ces enfants avec des
cartes de la municipalité puisque cette
chorale est en quelque sorte
subventionné par la municipalité ne
voulons pas subventionner la partie à la
municipalité dire que la municipalité
peut en faire ce qu'elle veut dans la
mesure de ses possibilités
celle qui donne l'orientation à la
chorale ainsi deux fois par semaine les
enfants des cités de la périphérie
d'angoulême se retrouve à une répétition
dirigée par jean-jacques sis au n est
accompagné par madame d'asnières alors
verryn usage unique
tous or vous devriez alors nous aider ça
à chaque marcheur que vous les comprenez
aïe
madame d'asnières quel est le répertoire
de de cette chorale enfantine et bien
nous voulons faire un répertoire moderne
mais le folklore d'une part mais nous
mettrons du schubert nous mettrons du
classique et des choses tout à fait
moderne puisque nous avons déjà
travaillé du beco nous avons travaillé
monsieur le maire eu la gentillesse de
nous faire une chanson ce qui nous fera
tout de même une chose moderne et puis
on fait il faut intéresser les enfants
avec des choses comme le des choses de
sheila des choses qui leur plaisent pour
les attirer beaucoup tout en leur
faisant travailler la musique pure
ainsi donc vous répéter dans les locaux
de la mairie d'angoulême mais vous
participez aussi je crois certaines de
ces manifestations
puis nous avons fait participent aux
manifestations officielles organisées
par la ville et emblème en particulier
le jumelage avec victoria et au moulin
le 23 96 me souviens bien
hu
mais
hahaha
le père noël magique
les maillots c'est état de santé
mais où
m
ras
à angoulême et montgardin train
vous serez chargé les mains